nous commençons les travaux de notre
commission d'enquête sur la
libéralisation du frais de ferroviaire
et ses conséquences
commissions d'enquête dont je rappelle
que le principe a été validé par la
commission du développement durable et
de l'aménagement du territoire dans une
réunion du 27 juin dernier et commission
d'enquête qui a installé son bureau le
19 juillet et dernier
nous ouvrons et nous en sommes très
heureux cette séance de travail qui va
nous emmener jusqu'à la fin du mois de
novembre
avec la présence de Monsieur Jean-Claude
guesseau ancien ministre de l'équipement
et des transports anciens députés de
Seine-Saint-Denis et ancien cheminot
ministre qui a vécu à la fois une
réforme importante ce qui avait été
votée avant l'arrivée du gouvernement
Jospin sur la création de Réseau ferré
de France et qui a fait railler on peut
le dire monsieur le ministre contre les
dispositions qui visaient à libéralisées
de frais de ferroviaire en tant qu'elles
étaient déjà soutenues à l'époque où
vous étiez au gouvernement par la
Commission européenne monsieur le
ministre je vous souhaite la bienvenue
devant cette commission d'enquête dans
ces murs que vous connaissez bien vous
venez de me le rappeler pour avoir
siéger à l'Assemblée nationale à
plusieurs reprises je vous remercie de
vous être rendus disponible pour cette
audition et je vous remercie d'ores et
déjà du témoignage que vous pourrez nous
apporter sur
la manière dont vous avez essayé comme
membre du gouvernement et avec ce
portefeuille ministériel des transports
que vous êtes je crois
dans la vie publique française
dont vous détenez le record de
d'exercice jusqu'à maintenant 5 ans vous
nous expliquerez donc la manière dont
vous avez entendu soutenir le frais de
ferroviaire dans votre action et dont à
l'époque déjà de certains opérateurs
alternatifs se positionner sur ce sur
ces marchés et puis nous accueillons à
vos côtés Monsieur Francis roll Tanguy
qui a été votre directeur de cabinet
pendant la première partie de votre
passage au ministère de l'équipement et
des transports jusqu'en 2000 et qui est
ensuite devenu pour trois ans le
directeur le patron du frais de
ferroviaire en France dans une période
elle aussi très singulière puisque c'est
celle qui a immédiatement précédé
l'ouverture à la concurrence effective
dans le droit en 2003 et effective dans
la réalité en 2005 merci Monsieur le à
vous aussi qui est engagé toujours dans
le débat citoyen de vous être rendu
disponible j'ai oublié de préciser
monsieur le ministre que vous étiez
président du port de Sète un port qui
est très dynamique aujourd'hui et que
forcément à ce titre vous vous posez
aussi des questions sur l'interaction
entre le frais de ferroviaire et les
autres modes de transport
cette audition je le précise et
retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale et l'ange
registrement vidéo bien sûr sera
disponible après ensuite à la demande
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
directeur avant de vous céder la parole
pour un exposé liminaire d'une quinzaine
de minutes alors j'ai cru comprendre que
vous aviez réglé votre balai de prise de
parole avant d'arriver mais on peut
comprendre puisque vous êtes deux que
l'audition dure un peu plus longtemps
que 15 minutes si vous le souhaitez en
tout cas je serai un peu moins rigoureux
qu'à l'ordinaire et on peut imaginer que
cette entre 15 minutes et une demi-heure
que vous interviendrez tous les deux et
donc avant de vous entendre vous le
savez nous sommes ici à l'Assemblée
nationale dans le cadre d'une commission
d'enquête et donc suivant les
dispositions de l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires je vais vous
demander de bien vouloir prêter serment
de dire la vérité toute la vérité rien
que la vérité dans l'audition qui suivra
je vous invite donc monsieur le ministre
et monsieur le directeur a levé la main
droite et à dire je le jure
je vous remercie vous avez donc la
parole pour entre 15 minutes et une
demi-heure
il faudrait brancher votre micro
monsieur ministre monsieur le président
j'avais pas prévu de commencer par ça
mais je vous dis tout de suite
vous m'avez traité d'ancien ministre
d'anciens cheminots mais vous savez que
la règle c'est toujours de m'appeler
monsieur le ministre
et que je suis toujours cheminant même
si je suis à la retraite
c'est de l'humour
permettez-moi monsieur le président
de saluer votre initiative
enfin
l'Assemblée nationale intervient
grâce à votre commission d'enquête
sur
l'avenir et les conséquences de la
libéralisation
concernant le fait de ferroviaire
je considère
que pour le fret et même au-delà
c'est à mes yeux d'une brûlante
actualité
la récente catastrophe en Savoie liée au
dérèglement climatique et d'urgence
d'accélérer le report modal en témoigne
je me présente bien sûr j'ai été
ministre de l'Équipement des Transports
du Logement du tourisme de plein
exercice
et de la météo mais la météo je le
disais que quand il faisait beau sinon
ça fait toujours engueuler alors
donc juin 97 c'est important juin 97 à
juin 2002
à ce titre et dans le cadre du
gouvernement de la gauche pluriel j'ai
eu à prendre ou à initier des
interventions et des choix
liés à l'engagement de l'État et à la
dépense publique
j'ai même présidé durant 6 mois l'Europe
des transports et de l'énergie en 2000
lors de la présidence française
mais sachez aussi vous l'avez dit
monsieur le président
que depuis
1962 je suis cheminot
à Béziers aux ateliers puis surtout
toute la ligne Béziers ne Sargue
clairement pour laquelle je continue à
me battre
comme militant syndical et politique je
n'ai eu de cesse
depuis plus de 60 ans
de promouvoir le train
fret et voyageurs
au nom
du développement durable
et quand je dis développement durable
j'insiste sur les deux termes
en 1979 j'ai avec Philippe Herzog
écrit un livre intitulé pour un nouveau
type de croissance
c'est à dire non productiviste
un nouveau type de croissance non
productiviste qui ne cause pas qui
n'oppose pas le développement
avec l'objectif majeur de la lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique et
contre les inégalités
depuis plus de 60 ans je suis mobilisé
pour en finir avait l'hypertrophie des
camions sur la route et pour un
aménagement du territoire qui n'osent
pas là aussi la grande vitesse avec les
lignes dites secondaires ou qu'on me dit
le président Macron les petites lignes
avec Francis rotendu d'ailleurs il vous
parlera il vous dira tout ce qu'il en
est il est vraiment dans le coup je vous
le dire et et on aura peut-être
l'occasion de voir ce qu'on peut faire
après pour comme pour vous donner tous
les éléments que que vous souhaitez sur
tout ce qui s'est passé se passe
aujourd'hui
je dis ça parce que quand il a été
question du développement du fret nous
et Francis
particulièrement concernée nous n'avons
pas opposé
les grands tringles des tringles des
longs trains avec
avec les wagons isolés
qui a existé
pratiquement dans toutes les gares
françaises
il y a près de près de 4000 4000 gares
où il y avait la possibilité
d'embranchement de wagons marchandises
isolés
et bye vous le dira elle est vraiment il
s'est mobilisé sur ces questions et pas
que ce sera là comme militant comme élu
local régional national comme président
du port de Sète et bien la question du
développement durable à totalement
imprégné mon ADN
je me plais d'ailleurs pardonnez-moi à
citer et Karl Marx
quand il disait que si le travail est le
père de toutes les richesses c'est la
terre qui en est la mère
l'ouverture à la concurrence est
inscrite dans la directive
91 dans la directive européenne 80 11
donc vraiment partie de cette de ce
moment là
alors que faisons-nous à partir de ce
moment-là que fait la France l'Union
européenne nos entreprises depuis c'est
la question qui nous interpelle
pour voir comment on va avoir l'avenir
1937 la SNCF est créée
51% de capital public
49% des anciennes compagnies privées
et qui doivent être
des eaux magiques dans les 45 ans qui
suivent
et en 1982
c'est 45 ans sont passés
la SNCF qui avait le statut de société
anonyme est devenu un épique 100% public
et c'est en 1982
chez la période
où avec Charles Fiterman et Mauroy
et bien est engagé la loterie la loi
d'orientation pour les transports
intérieurs et qui va valorise la
complémentarité et le développement du
la promotion du ferroviaire
00 est d'ailleurs Francis Roland Tanguy
parce que là vous avez pas mis grand
chose mais il était à ce moment-là
dans le gouvernement de
Pierre Mauroy avec Charles Fiterman
aux manettes sur ces questions vous
voyez que ça vaut le coup d'en avoir
invité
même si vous aviez oublié au départ
et
en 1997 et mise en œuvre la
91440 et créer RFS c'est-à-dire la
séparation
les réseaux
et de l'exploitation
et créer RFF mais 97 évidemment
on se dit mais c'est en 97 que les
choses qui ont été immédies oui c'est en
97 mais créer
RFF sur la base de la directive
91440 en février et le 16 mai c'est
concrétiser
c'est-à-dire quelques jours avant que
nous arrivions au responsabilités
alors c'était Juppé c'était bon c'était
Anne-Marie Irak avec je crois que vous
avez prévu de tous les consulter voilà
2001 trois directives européennes
demandent l'ouverture à la concurrence
du fret ferroviaire mais limité au
réseau européen des transports
donc voilà un peu je dis ça pour voir ce
qui se passe
c'est à dire avant que nous arrivions
responsabilités et puis on verra après
au gouvernement de juin 97 juin 2002
mobilisé pour le report mandat
ça a été notre obsession
avec une double dimension
d'abord ce que je dis
sur cet ADN
le travail la planète
le développement durable
et avec cette sentiment que la France
est un pays de transit au cœur de
l'Europe et que si on fait pas ce qu'il
faut si on fait pas ce qu'il faut et
bien on va on va dans le mur en ce qui
concerne justement cette question
majeure donc qu'avons-nous fait d'abord
des endettement massifs de la SNCF
d'abord
de la SNCF
renforcement des effectifs des cheminots
liés au fret parce qu'on nous reprochait
l'inefficacité
du fret avec les ruptures de charges
avec le savait même pas les quand elles
ou passer les les wagons à quel endroit
ils étaient donc fallait renforcer
l'effet science l'efficacité de du
transport du transport
Ferré c'est aussi à ce moment-là que
nous avons fait le choix
et d'ailleurs Bussereau était concerné
je crois à l'époque de
du wagon mode alors vous savez ce que
c'est le wagon mandalor c'est pour faire
le chargement non plus vertical mais le
chargement horizontal nous pouvons
charger en une
demi-heure un train complet de camion
sur
de camions sur le rail voilà c'est bon
alors c'est ce que je fais d'ailleurs ce
que on est en train d'initier au port au
port au port de Sète l'Efficient
l'efficacité du transport ferroviaire
marchandises
et puis nous avons même
je dois reconnaître adsk
qu'il a été d'accord
l'achat de 600 locomotives frais
spécialisées les 25000
il y a pas de cheminots parmi vous ce
sont des locomotives et comment elles
sont quelle couleur blanche et verte
et il y a marqué Fred dessus
parce que j'avais fait la proposition de
doubler le transport
ferroviaire en marchandise sur nous
étions à 54 milliards de tonnes de
kilomètres
et je proposais de doubler d'ailleurs
certains m'engueulés en me disant
c'est pas terrible quand même simplement
doublé avec tout ce qu'il y a à faire
je vous dirai où on en est aujourd'hui
et voilà
création du Conseil supérieur du service
public ferroviaire
pour faire en sorte que les députés les
députés je dis bien mais aussi les les
cheminots réseau ferrés de France la
SNCF donc et avec les députés présents
on travaille d'ailleurs c'était comment
s'appelait filleul
fiole qui était Président du Conseil
supérieur
tout ça c'est pourquoi je dis que votre
initiative a le s’inscrire que
l'Assemblée nationale se prennent cette
question à bras le corps c'est très très
bien je veux vraiment je salue cette
initiative
et puis nous avions décidé de prolonger
la durée des autoroutes qui n'étaient
pas privatisées
mais elles étaient toutes déficitaires
pourquoi prolonger pour permettre avec
cette prolongation elle dégage des
bénéfices et que ces bénéfices et bien
ils puissent servir au report modal y
compris pour aller sur le ferroviaire
et ne croyez pas que c'est du
langage comme ça du discours nous avons
fait y compris si je me rappelle c'était
dans les Alpes il y a eu un problème à
un moment donné avec les sociétés
d'autoroute nous avons reversé 70
millions pour le
pardonnez-moi les chiffres vous
vérifierez ainsi si parce que à mon âge
ma mémoire des fois et
voyez c'était et je mets mon tenue je me
souviendrai toujours Laurent fabioche
qui a été pour qu'on ouvre le capital de
de la neuve
sans la privatiser mais je suis plus la
somme que ça avait fait
quand je parlais tout à l'heure on a
parlé tous les deux de 40 millions il
m'a dit mais c'est plus que ça et mais
tout récent une société publique puisque
capital privé était minoritaire j'avais
même obtenu de Laurent Fabius
directement puisque je me suis battu
pour cela aussi
que cet argent qui allait être engrangé
par l'État servent pour le report modal
et pour
officiellement
bon
avec l'idée de la multi modalité
l'idée de
vous savez avec les États-Unis
c'est d'ailleurs
[Musique]
en haut de la tour
je signais un accord avec
le ministre
américain et la terre
sur
comment faire en sorte
de faire avancer la complémentarité des
transports de telle manière qu'on
utilise au mieux chaque mort de
transport lorsqu'on veut aller du point
A au point x
et bien nous avons signé un accord par
exemple sur qui disait
je pars des États-Unis
je viens en France
et je veux aller à Lyon
où je veux aller à Marseille où je veux
aller à Toulouse et bien avec un billet
unique
sans rupture de charge
je prends l'avion puis je prends le
train
et c'est d'ailleurs ce que Antoine
veille me proposer de faire
Marie dans de six mois de veille pour
aller de la gare de l'Est
à Roissy
et partir vers où on veut c'est à dire
tu es entré dans la gare
tu prenais le train
la vérification on se faisait à la gare
et hop pas de rupture tu partais après
dans l'avion
cette démarche de l'internealité de la
complémentarité qui favorise les
transports les plus utiles les plus
efficaces pour aller du point boire au
point B en même temps que le report
modal ça a été
une obsession voilà et puis j'appelle ça
d'ailleurs le sixième monde des
transports il y a seulement de transport
moi j'appelle ça le sixième board cet
Inter modalités cette complémentarité
et puis il y a eu le choix de faire le
lion Turin
passé des dizaines des centaines de
milliers de camions de la route sur le
rail à ce propos je vous dis tout
je viens de demander d'écrire à la
première ministre
pour que on accélère
le processus
le tunnel est en train de se faire
il y a deux
et la question qui se pose depuis
quelques temps et la suivante oui mais
ça coûte cher pour le raccordement entre
le tunnel de base et notre pouvoir
Ferrer Lyon
et je vous dis pas la mobilisation qui
est la mienne et qui est la nôtre
pour que
y compris en prenant en compte ceux qui
viennent de se passer
en savoir les boulements tout le monde
dit que c'est lié au dérèglement
climatique la ligne ancienne 190 ans
d'âge de Modane
ça fait quatre
fois qu'elle est qu'elle est arrêtée en
quelques en quelques années et
ce qu'on dit ce qu'on nous dit oui mais
ça coûte cher tu t'imagines on peut pas
tout faire d'un coup je vais reparler de
ça mais je crois que votre question sur
la libéralisation elle porte le problème
des choix de dépenses publiques
aujourd'hui qui sont majeurs dans
Lyon-Turin et puis la loi srue qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire avec la loi LC rue la loi
srue bien sûr c'est le logement social
c'est les 20% de gens dans le logement
social etc mais c'est pas que ça
c'est aussi
la régionalisation du du transport
ferroviaire la régionalisation avec une
idée
simple permettre aux régions et au
comité de ligne que nous mettons en
place
tout ça pour parler de démocratie
participative aussi si on veut changer
le cours des choses il faut aussi
intégrer qui a pas que la représentation
et la démocratie représentative mais
qu'il faut mieux articuler avec
démocratie
participative si on veut faire avancer
le schmilblick et j'y crois profondément
et bien dans cette loi nous avons
régionalisé
et je vous dis pas l'augmentation
société sur la base d'une
expérimentation qui existait déjà nous
avons généralisé et sur cette base là
je suis dans les temps chef
tu m'as dit de meilleur pour les deux
monsieur le ministre alors aujourd'hui à
combien moi normalement on a jusqu'à 39
donc il reste 11 minutes et ben je vais
finir en deux minutes alors
aujourd'hui face aux dérèglement
climatique la pertinence du reportage
sont aux yeux de tous alors la question
qui est posée et cela libération qui
peut régler le problème je réponds
catégoriquement non que ce soit pour le
fret ou pour le voyageur ce qui doit
dominer c'est l'intérêt général et à mon
avis le transport de ferroviaire de Fred
doit devenir un véritable service public
certes la part du privé depuis 2001 est
passé de 01% à 30% aujourd'hui mais le
dommage n'a fait que baisser on éloigne
d'avoir multiplié par deux 54 milliards
de tonnes je vous disais pour la divisé
par deux depuis 2002 qu'il s'agisse de
la privatisation des autoroutes des
directives européennes de l'intervention
de l'UE contre la SNCF fret je suis
d'ailleurs de ce point de vue d'accord
avec tous les syndicats qui se battent
qui se mobilisent contre contre contre
cela et de plus il faut accélérer le
lien Turin et engager à l'échelle Union
européenne et en France y compris en
veillant à ce que la France et l'Europe
l'Europe et la France
ontaricule mieux sur cette question qui
dépasse nos frontières et qui concerne
la planète toute entière et bien dans le
cadre des budgets de dépenses publiques
nous nous agissons ne pas se contenter
des très longs comme je dis tout à
l'heure qu'il faut
mais aussi les wagons isolés des
plateformes multimodal pour renforcer la
dépense vous me direz mais où trouver de
l'argent mais pour pas être plus long je
vous autorise à me poser la question
Francis on va peut-être donner tout de
suite la parole à Monsieur roletangui
puis ensuite on passera effectivement à
mes questions à celle bien sûr du
rapporteur ubervil Franck est à
l'origine de cette commission d'enquête
avec son groupe et puis ensuite aux
questions des collègues monsieur roll
Tanguy nous vous écoutons
je vais être court parce que
je vais je vais faire court parce que
moi j'en ai pas prévu d'intervention je
veux dire moi je suis pas élu je veux
dire je vais pas me rentrer dans le
débat politique autour de la
libéralisation
juste deux trois choses d'abord c'est
vrai que l'actualité de cette commission
est très singulière puisque c'est le
moment où
la Commission a engager une procédure
contre Fret SNCF qui se traduit
aujourd'hui par si je comprends bien une
décision ou un accord
et donc c'est quand même un point assez
singulier que la Commission qui depuis
2005 ferme les yeux sur le fait que la
SNCF a compensé tous les déficits du
Fred dans cette période là et c'est
juste au moment où fêter SNCF sort la
tête de loup puisque ces deux derniers
exercices il était à Zéro Plus
est intenté cette procédure alors qu'il
n'y avait plus de plainte de la part des
concurrents de Frat SNCF et que tout ça
va se traduire forcément par une
régression car le privé ne reprendra pas
tous les trafics que ferait SNCF est
obligé par cet accord de 1 de qui sont
obligés de sur lesquels ils sont obligés
de se désengager c'est pas c'est pas
même pas une critique vis-à-vis du privé
c'est un simple constat les choses se
passent pas comme ça donc je veux dire
il y a une vraie actualité particulière
à cause de cet accord aujourd'hui et de
cette procédure engagée par la
commission sur des faits qui en réalité
ont presque 20 ans quoi je veux dire
enfin tous les cas se déroulent depuis
presque 20 ans donc ça c'est la première
chose que je voudrais dire sur
l'actualité de cette commission les deux
autres choses on va dire aussi c'est que
au début des années 2000 moi quand
j'étais directeur du Fred fin directeur
de cabinet puis directeur général
délégué fret à la SNCF
la libéralisation était si je puis dire
un fait à qui avec la interactif de 91
même si après elle s'est traduite en
2001 puis comme vous l'avez signalé la
transcription en 2003 et puis
l'ouverture réelle en 2005 mais c'était
quelque part prendre enfin en compte la
dimension européenne du fret du frais de
fervier et c'est ce que la France
je dirais parce que c'est pas seulement
la SNCF mais c'est ce que la SNCF et le
gouvernement ont raté à partir de 2003
je ne dis pas seulement parce que un
parce que j'ai été remercié à cette
époque et donc je me suis consacré à
d'autres responsabilités après
dire moi j'étais normal quand on est
dans des fonctions comme celle-là et
qu'on vous demande de remettre votre
démission vous la remettez je veux dire
c'est pas ça se discute pas c'est
logique je veux dire c'est on sait bien
qu'on est anotom même si c'est pas même
si c'est pas la question mais c'était
bien sur un désaccord stratégique là
dessus puisque derrière la politique de
la SNCF et du gouvernement a été de
traiter le fret en franco-français et
c'est pour ça qu'il s'est réduit comme
ça parce que si on
donc moi je voudrais quand même aussi
marqué ça dans sur cette question de la
libéralisation il faut regarder la prise
en compte de la dimension européenne du
fret et ça la SNCF la rater je peux
s'expliquer un peu plus là-dessus mais
c'est une évidence et la deuxième chose
c'est justement à partir du moment à
partir de 2003 où on dit qu'on va
réduire le déficit de Frat SNCF qui
s'est quand même maintenu à la même
hauteur 300 millions d'euros pendant 10
ans
bah c'est là où on remet en cause les
wagons isolés moi c'est vrai que je
défendais pas cette stratégie quand je
dis directeur du fret et c'est pas la
stratégie qu'avec a choisi des bécargots
qui est la progresser la stratégie qui a
choisi des bécargots je pense que vous
avez d'autres auditions vous le verrez
peut-être c'était de dire je continue le
wagon isolé mais je fais en sorte que
les desserts terminales soient faits par
des petits opérateurs ferroviaires
1 et c'est ça qui changeait toute la
donne et vous verrez comment aujourd'hui
enfin je pense que si je passe vous avez
dans les auditions mais il y a tout un
mouvement des organisations qui se
battent pour le développement
d'opérateurs ferroviaire de proximité
c'est un peu tard je dirais puisque
entre temps on a quand même perdu la
moitié du marché donc je veux dire bon
c'est naturellement compliqué mais non
ça n'a d'intérêt que par que si on manie
les deux les trains entiers et les
wagons isolés tous nos tous les autres
pays européens
développé comme l'Allemagne par exemple
je veux dire le montre c'est une c'est
une démonstration là il y a un modèle
économique que la SNCF je veux dire
peut-être aujourd'hui je veux dire à
remet un peu en exergue depuis qu'il y a
quand même un président qui croit un peu
au fret ce qui n'est pas le cas des
précédents des précédents présidents
mais c'est une question c'est une
question centrale c'est exactement la
même chose que dans le voyageur je veux
dire c'est quand vous mettez une offre
de service en place comme comme on le
fait par exemple pour les TGV bah il
faut les remplir je veux dire c'est ça
la question et à partir de ce moment-là
c'est d'avoir une politique commerciale
pour les remplir
et c'est ça que que le wagon isolé
permet moi je vous citerai juste un
exemple quand j'étais directeur du fret
on avait le premier client à l'époque
s'appelait Usinor on dirait arcelorm
maintenant et je pense que c'est plus le
premier client parce que tous ces
trafics qui allaient vers l'acide orgie
Lorraine bah par définition je ne pense
pas il existe encore en tous les cas la
même hauteur aujourd'hui c'est une
évidence mais je veux dire mon homologue
qui était le directeur de la logistique
il me le disait clairement il me disait
mais votre entier
sont trop chers et la concurrence vous
les prendra parce que c'est le plus
simple à faire par contre wagon isolé
sont pas assez cher et ça j'en ai besoin
aussi et je pense que c'est la chimie a
besoin du wagon isolé pourquoi parce que
faire des trains entiers de produits
chimiques c'est prendre un risque
colossal c'est commencer à se mettre à
la hauteur du risque nucléaire quoi je
veux dire donc je veux dire c'est pour
ça que la chimie naturellement préfère
les wagons isolés vaut mieux qu'il y ait
deux trois quatre wagons de chimiques un
train entier donc voilà je veux dire
c'est des exemples qui montrent que là
il y a eu un déni du modèle économique
ou en tous les cas un choix de modèle
économique conscient ou inconscient je
sais pas je veux pas me postuler qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui effectivement on a
divisé par deux le frais de ferroviaire
entre 2000 et 2020 quoi
merci merci à vous deux je vais
commencer donc la salle des questions et
on vous donnera tout de suite la parole
pour les réponses et ensuite c'est super
le franc rapporteur de cette commission
d'enquête qui vous posera ces questions
ensuite les collègues pourront le faire
si le souhaite
je voudrais retenir un certain nombre
des éléments de ce que vous avez dit
d'abord il y a cet effet du du la baisse
de par modèle qui avait commencé en fait
depuis les années 50-60 qu'il faut
préciser il y a des visions par 3 de la
part modèle du frais de ferroviaire
entre 1958 et 1994 donc une chute qui
venait qui était très liée à l'aide des
industrialisations mais dans ce que vous
venez de dire sur oltenguy il y a des
points sur lesquels la commission
d'enquête aimerait sans doute vous
entendre que vous explicitiez la notion
de l'échec d'une stratégie européenne au
moment où monsieur guesseau était
ministre des transports de l'équipement
du logement et du tourisme dans les
prises de parole qui étaient les siennes
il était souvent mis en avant
coordination entre les opérateurs de
fret à l'échelle européenne
donc c'est pour la raison pour laquelle
j'aimerais vous entendre sur cet échec
de la dimension européenne qu'est-ce
qu'il aurait fait faire et qu'est-ce
qu'il faudrait faire pour jouer vraiment
la dimension européenne du du frais de
ferroviaire deuxième question comment
vous évaluez les effets de la mauvaise
qualité de nos infrastructures
ferroviaires et de leur vieillissement
très très accéléré depuis le début des
années 90 sur la qualité des sillons et
sur la possibilité de faire du frais de
ferroviaire en France
vous avez aussi monsieur roll Tanguy
troisième question vous avez
pointé le faible intérêt de plusieurs
dirigeants de la SNCF du groupe public
ferroviaire pour le frais de ferroviaire
c'est un sentiment que beaucoup de
chargeurs ont le fait que au sein de la
maison SNCF le fret n'a pas été une
priorité pendant une bonne vingtaine
d'années comment est-ce que vous voulez
payer le nourrissez de d'exemples que
vous avez vécu puis enfin une dernière
question sur le modèle que vous évoquez
c'est à dire sur le wagon isolé
comment aujourd'hui alors que la
stratégie nationale de développement du
frais de ferroviaire se déploie qu'en
fin on a des acteurs du frais de
ferroviaire qui parle d'une seule voix
puisqu'ils sont fédérés au sein de 4F
qui n'était pas le cas au moment où vous
étiez responsabilités c'était sans doute
une difficulté pour vous comment est-ce
qu'on dynamise ce modèle du wagon isolé
avec des opérateurs servir de proximité
moi quand je suis nommé directeur
général délégué frais je crois que
c'était avril 2000
je ne sais plus vous dire à date c'était
2001 où il y a eu un renouvellement du
conseil administration de la SNCF et sur
proposition de Louis Gallois et avec
l'accord de Jean-Claude guesson le
président des chemins de fer Suisse a
été nommé au Conseil administration
au-delà du fait que sa manifestait cette
question européenne parce que quand même
la Suisse c'est vraiment une rotule au
sein du système puisque la banane bleue
c'est Italie Angleterre je veux dire il
y a pas il y a pas photo
il y avait une idée derrière c'était de
rapprocher le fret SNCF du fret Suisse
et moi j'ai travaillé naturellement dans
cette dans cette hypothèse qui n'était
pas publique mais qui était quand même
sous-jacente enfin au niveau de
Jean-Claude et de Louis Gallois et en
février 2003 on a tenu notre ultime
séminaire
pour faire les propositions au CA
respectif pour entre guillemets
fusionner c'est pas une fusion
capitalistique enfin voilà
bon moi ça fait février 2003 qu'on m'a
dit qu'il fallait que je sorte ma lettre
de démission et j'ai dit à Louis Gallois
qu'elle était dans son tiroir il pouvait
la sortir je vais vous dire les choses
franchement je pense que c'est un accord
politique le comité exécutif de la SNCF
avait d'une tête très à gauche
avec des directeurs comme Guillaume Pepy
comme paulmanga son qui était secrétaire
général comme claire Dreyfus clarec
était la directrice financière on était
tous passés dans les cabinets de gauche
il y avait pas de pas de mystère les CV
le prouve donc il y a une pression pour
dire pour reconduire Louis Gallois comme
président il faut quand même que des
têtes tombent et c'est sûr que le Fred
était naturellement celui où il y avait
un résultat financier détestable donc
dans la liste il sortait en premier et
puis en plus bon moi j'avais été auprès
d'un ministre communiste donc je veux
dire j'avais tout pour plaire mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que dans ces
trois ans j'avais construit de rapport
avec mes homologues européens trois ans
pour un directeur du fret ça n'a pas de
sens je veux dire si ça dure pas
d'ailleurs
la réussite de Guillaume Pepy sur le
voyageur a du TGV c'est aussi
c'est la durée je veux dire c'est pas
lui faire offense que de dire que c'est
aussi parce que il a réussi à maintenir
sa stratégie de volume sur le TGV qu'il
a réussi à gagner quand on en change
tous les trois ans directement du fret
et c'est ce qui s'est passé après vous
avez pas le temps de construire parce
que les relations européennes elles sont
très personnalisées parce qu'on a des
cultures différentes des histoires
différentes donc si les hommes
commencent sous les femmes commencent à
se faire confiance on peut construire
ensemble mais ça cette confiance là vous
la gagnez pas en claquant des doigts et
c'est vrai qu'à ce moment de 2003 on
était prêt à rapprocher les frettes
français et suisses mais il y avait une
condition et je pense que Louis Gallois
a partagé pas c'était qu'il fallait
attaquer l'Allemagne parce que pour les
Suisses je veux dire si on allait pas
attaquer les Allemands ça n'avait pas de
sens et ça à l'époque c'était pas la
ligne de la SNCF c'était pas la ligne de
la DB on avait deux dirigeants qui
étaient passés par ADS ils pensaient
qu'un jour il y aurait un fret européen
comme Airbus voilà
et c'est comme ça que tous nos accords
ne pouvaient pas marcher avec les Belges
on discutait tout le temps on a une
proximité absolument évidente sauf que
économiquement les Belges pour eux le
Fred ferroviaire c'est le port d'Anvers
et le port d'Anvers c'est l'Allemagne si
vous mettez pas un pied en Allemagne
personne ne fera alliance avec les
Belges les Belges ne faisaient pas
alliance avec nous on discutait beaucoup
on était très proche on s'aimait bien
etc mais quand il fallait c'était la
question sous-jacente c'était est-ce que
vous allez est-ce que vous allez en
Allemagne bon je veux dire à l'époque
c'est vrai que moi j'avais pris compris
des contacts politiques en Allemagne
pour savoir si on aurait la neutralité
bienveillante si quelque part via les
Suisses les Français attaquer c'était
possible je pense que la politique
française en a tranché autrement sans
tenir compte du tout de ces éléments là
vous donnez un dernier exemple en
Espagne vous ferez de ferroviaire a été
très faible il y avait une petite
entreprise entre guillemets familiale
qui s'appelait transfeza qui aujourd'hui
le numéro 1 du frais de ferroviaire en
Espagne
qui faisait les changements des cieux
puisque comme on n'avait pas le même
écartement c'est elle qui avait les
changements des cieux avec la SNCF les
deux côtés de la frontière dans cette
entreprise familiale la famille avait
60% la filiale de transport de véhicule
STVA de la SNCF avait 20 % et la SNCF
avait 20 % directement et ben en 2006 la
DB a racheté les 60% de la famille et la
SNCF a vendu ses 40% ben naturellement
il y avait plus d'intérêt alors que je
veux dire la logique c'était que ce soit
pour la SNCF et quand même avec des
trafics très importants parce que
l'industrie automobile en Allemagne
Allemagne Espagne c'est un axe très
important pour l'industrie automobile
pas seulement pour transporter des
voitures transportées aussi des pièces
détachées voilà donc c'est le moment où
on a on a tout lâché il y a eu
l'arbitrage quand même pour garder
ermeva qui est quand même le deuxième
loueur de wagon en Europe qui était une
entreprise suisse ou la SNCF était avec
les amis puis après être venu
majoritaire
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait là il y a 5 ans
on l'a revendu pour un milliard je veux
dire donc tous ces éléments qui nous
donnaient des capacités de développement
européen de prendre notre place comme la
DB la fin en Europe bah c'est la période
là de 2010 on a tout lâché je veux dire
et on est resté franco-français
naturellement le marché c'est pas c'est
pas l'acide chirurgie aujourd'hui c'est
pas le charbon c'est pas toutes ces qui
suppose des trains entiers c'est autre
chose je veux dire et donc je veux dire
c'est ça que de tout le monde qui a pas
été pris bon la mauvaise qualité de
l'Infra et surtout de bon et de la
maintenance de l'Infra on va dire oui
bah oui naturellement que ça favorise
pas le fret mais je dirais que là pour
le coup ça vaporise pas non plus les
voyageurs en dehors des lignes nouvelles
TGV je veux dire c'est les deux les deux
pays
et quand au faible intérêt je sais pas
c'est pas faible intéresse c'est que
c'était porté comme un boulet parce que
le fret avait ses déficit et dans la
pression permanente qui s'exerce sur la
SNCF sur ses comptes bah naturellement
que celui qui traîne le boulet du
déficit pour une part bah je veux dire
il est pas il est pas très bien vu il y
a rien à dire là-dessus ce que tout le
monde a oublié comme vous le dites c'est
qu'à partir de à partir de début des
années 80
que
le fret n'est plus ne rapporte plus
d'argent à la SNCF
mais pendant toutes les années 70 et 80
qui a payé Paris Lyon TGV c'est le fret
c'est le fret qui a payé pareil Lyon TGV
c'est pas les voyageurs voilà c'est des
périodes différentes c'est des marchés
diffusées des marchés qui évoluent c'est
voilà bon donc oui
persiste à penser que il y a d'autres
intérêts qui sont passés avant ceux du
frais pour vous donner un exemple
puisque vous en vouliez un
le tunnel sous la Manche est inauguré et
on y met des pH ferroviaires faramineux
inaccessible à n'importe quelle
opérateur ferroviaire
qu'est-ce qu'on fait d'un côté pour les
voyageurs on dit bon on va dire quel est
le pH admissible pour Eurostar et donc
Eurostar va contribuer à la hauteur de
un peu moins de X sur deux et l'autre on
va le mettre dans une société de
diffusion
l'autre partie
1 et il y a eu cette société cette
société diffusant ce qui a été mise à
côté de Rostar et qui finalement les
gouvernements anglais et français ont
réglé à partir du moment où il y a plus
la minimale les autres charges ok ah
sauf que le fret non il n'y a pas eu de
société de diffusance le fret payait les
péages plein pot
oui ça faisait partie des déficits du
fret et c'était pas un million ou deux
sur 300 je peux vous dire que ça se
comptait en dizaines des phénomènes
comme ça
il y avait un autre un autre débat avec
c'est que en terme de terrain
ferroviaire quand même je veux dire ça a
quand même beaucoup aidé la SNCF de
vendre des terrains ferroviaires la
grande partie et c'est normal vous voyez
même quand vous voyez des vieilles gares
vous voyez qu'à côté il y a la halle il
y a l'ancienne Alfred enfin je veux dire
il suffit de se promener pour voir ça et
ben trois quarts des terrains étaient
portés par le frais ça veut dire le
minimum d'entretien de gardiennage de
taxes à payer je veux dire bah c'était
le Fred qui les payait sur ce qui a été
quand même une ressource qui a financé
la SNCF de manière significative dans
les 10 ou 20 ans qui viennent de se
passer mais en attendant quand vous avez
un terrain il faut bien y faire le
minimum et payer les charges tout ça
était dans les contes du fret ils
étaient pas ailleurs donc oui ces
éléments là moi j'ai pas réussi à les
faire bouger mais ces éléments là
péjoraient les contes du fret au-delà du
vrai résultat économique
je suis pas en train de dire que le
résultat économique était mirifique
c'est pas ça je veux dire mais ça
montrait bien qu'il y avait pas qu'il y
avait pas ce truc de dire il faut qu'on
trouve des solutions pour pour faire
mieux quoi
tout ce que vient de dire Francis est
très très important
quand on dit
échec
de l'Europe de la prise en compte de la
dimension européenne du problème c'est
ça qu'on parle vous savez quand il y a
eu cette cette
91440 et cette séparation
disons RFS SNCF
et bien j'étais député
et avec mes amis
socialistes nous avons voté contre
je me suis retrouvé
quelques mois après quelques mois après
avec cette interrogation
mais comme il y avait eu un transfert de
plus de 20 milliards je crois de
dettes
la problématique à laquelle nous avons
été confrontés mais je rappelle que la
91440 c'est le début du commencement de
la libéralisation du fret ferroviaire
avec un objectif comment enrayer le
déclin du fret ferroviaire abaissant ils
ont réussi
tout faux
tout faux sauf dans certains pays on va
parler de l'Italie et de l'Allemagne où
ils se sont servis de cette capacité
d'être hors service public
pour acheter pour les Allemands de ce
point de vue la DB ils ont été ça ils
ont été plus marial que nous sur
d'autres sur d'autres aspects mais
j'insiste sur la sur cette question
parce que bien sûr ce que dit Francis
enfin vous êtes responsabilité vous
savez comment ça marche
plus signé des
en cinq ans des accords y compris avec
les Américains il faut le faire qui
était où on me portait y compris aux
États-Unis
parce que ces rapports ce travail est
compris
de persuasion de discussions de voir
sans faire de compromission mais qu'elle
compromis on peut faire pour qu'il n'y
ait pas de perdant perdant mais qui est
des gagnants c'est comme ça vous savez
le CFM 56 l'avion le moteur qui vote le
plus dans le monde moi c'est avait
général électrique et chaque voyage que
j'ai pu régler le problème pour que et
bien l'accord soit 55 ans
c'est bon et bon je passe là-dessus
c'est que vous vous avez
posé le problème de la maintenance
mais que ce soit
sur
la question dont on vient de parler que
ce soit sur le problème de la
maintenance
y compris aujourd'hui je vous assure je
prends le train moi je prends le train
chaque fois que je peux
pour venir à Paris chaque fois que je
peux je prends le train
et d'ailleurs il faudra que on m'amène à
la gare de tout à l'heure pour pas que
je le manque parce que sinon je vais me
faire engueuler
bon alors
le problème de la maintenance parce que
c'est vrai qu'on a un problème de
maintenance aujourd'hui
on fait les retards les difficultés on
les vies on les vit tous les jours je
mets pas en cause
le président de la SNCF ce que je mets
en cause c'est que chaque fois on nous
dit
on peut pas la dépense publique
le nombre de cheminots je vous ai parlé
de
41.000 emplois de cheminots en 5 ans ou
enfin on avait enrayé la chute libre bon
c'est vrai on demande pas de revenir en
37 où il y a 500 000 ils étaient
mais
déclin sur déclin on s'arrête pas et
ceux qui verrouillait le plus c'était
sur la partie marchandise et sur les
contrôleurs et sur
bon
si on continue comme ça
à penser
uniquement en termes
de rentabilité et d'efficacité
financières
je vous ai dit vous pouvez poser moi la
question oui mais alors ghetto comment
on fait
j'espère que le va venir cette question
mais si le choix par rapport à un enjeu
majeur
ne se fait pas contre les directives
européennes je dis bien contre les
directives européennes et qui privilégie
sans arrêt
la recherche en fait la loi du marché
pour aller vivre moi je suis pas contre
le marché je suis contre la dictature de
la loi du marché
vous entendez je suis pas contre le
marché je contre la dictature de la loi
du marché et on a fait on vient de faire
y compris
une réforme
des retraites vous me direz des
cheminots sont aussi un peu concernés et
au nom de quoi
la pression des marchés financiers et
tant qu'on restera là franchement je
vous le dis je le ressens très
profondément
tant qu'on en restera là subir cette
dictature là de la de la loi du marché
qui est dit oui mais attention si si tu
fais pas la réforme des retraites tu vas
voir un peu comment comment ils vont te
trier
dans les taux d'intérêt derrière donc
puisque c'est une commission qui pose le
problème de la du risque de la
libéralisation disons
et bien je crois qu'il faut intégrer
cette dimension
mais merci
juste je vais passer tout de suite la
parole rapporteur mais
avec tout le respect que je vous dois
l'une des l'un des points qu'on a
identifié dans l'intervention de
Monsieur oltenguy c'était cette idée que
avec les mêmes réformes
appliqué avec les mêmes directives
européennes et la même logique dans des
pays européens on avait accru la part du
frais de ferroviaire et en France elle a
décéléré c'est donc il y a une
spécificité française dans la manière
dont ce sujet a été traité plus qu'un
sujet qui serait un sujet d'économie
générale monsieur le rapporteur
voilà
merci de vous vos premières
contributions moi monsieur le ministre
je voudrais vous interroger sur
rapidement bien évidemment le temps nous
est compté sur votre arrivée au
ministère face à et bien une réforme qui
est intervenue et que vous prenez donc
en considération avec RFS un réseau
ferry de France qui est votre votre
interlocuteur
et
dont on dit dont on dit dont y compris
certains experts disent que dans le
ferroviaire on est passé de l'ingénieur
à l'économiste et que RFF est guidé à
partir de ces années et bien par une
logique tout à fait différente de ce
qu'elle était auparavant comment
avez-vous
senti et bien cette inclinaison je
dirais politique au sens noble du terme
de de l'entité réseau et les
conséquences que vous en avez que vous
avez pu en tirer durant votre votre
ministère ça c'est la première question
deuxième question
monsieur Rol-Tanguy l'a indiqué
vous êtes inscrit en fou à un moment
donné contre c'est abandon du wagon
isolé
considère vous-même qu'il aurait convenu
de continuer cette politique peut-être
en faisant payer le service du vallon du
wagon isolé à son juste prix et en
lisant y compris
l'actualité de l'époque la SNCF dit
aussi perdre de l'argent à l'époque sur
le trafic du transport combiné
d'ailleurs je crois qu'il y a une crise
dans les années 2000 avec les chargeurs
et la SNCF sur et bien le modèle
économique du du transport combiné ce
que vous pourriez nous éclairer donc sur
sur ces questions merci
effectivement je voulais dire je le
répète pour que les choses soient bien
claires
donc quand il y a eu cette réforme de
séparation
de division de groupes la SNCF RF comme
député
je suis pas le seul nous avons voté
contre avec nos amis socialistes c'est
ça je me trompe pas
donc et
il avait que 20 milliards avaient été
disons déplacé et je me suis retrouvé
dans cette situation
il y a où je remets 20 milliards de
dettes sur la SNCF
et là
c'était pas un premier ministre
communiste qui a été mis en président de
la République communiste qui était donc
j'ai beaucoup vraiment beaucoup
travaillé à cette sur cette question
pour faire en sorte y compris je dois le
dire avec toute la franchise qui est
qu'avec comment il s'appelait Martin
le président de RFS
et bien nous travaillons mais dans la
main
pour faire en sorte que
la SNCF SNCF prête
et bien ne sois pas
les gens remise en cause dans sa
perspective de développement et même y
compris de multiplier par deux le trafic
ferroviaire je vous ai parlé de 54
milliards de tonnes si j'en crois
Francis il m'a dit non c'est 55
milliards bon alors lui c'est 55
millions
je parle des milliards de tonnes je
parle de milliard de ton de km par le
pas de Miron de ton km je parle de
milliard de 30 km
je crois
bon après vous vérifierez
dans cette dimension
l'obsession que nous avons eu
ça a été de créer
ce conseil supérieur
du service public ferroviaire avec vous
les députés
ce serait pas mal que vous les
interviewez d'ailleurs j'ai pas vu dans
la liste qui y soit
ils sont dans la liste vous avez prévu
de les intervenir
ça a été le premier non le premier
président du Conseil supérieur du
service public
j'ai bien compris et bien compris
d'ailleurs j'ai vu comment tu es mais
c'est le don cette cette mais je vous
avoue
que
je me suis fortement fortement interrogé
pour non pas pendant que j'étais au
gouvernement mais après ce qui s'est
passé après 201 disons quand on a été
injecté du gouvernement
je me suis fortement fortement interrogé
s'il fallait pas mener la bagarre
pour
que RSF et SNCF redeviennent le groupe E
là SNCF avec sa partie Fred et sa partie
mais que ce soit la même entité je vous
avoue et je crois que peut-être
ça peut être une idée derrière de telle
sorte que
vous savez
les wagons isolés
vous savez on parlait de la sidérurgie
bien sûr
on a
[Musique]
exporter nos entreprises à part les
Allemands qui ont gardé le charbon ce
qui fait que ça fait du fret
du fret important nous toutes nos
entreprises
industrielles ont été délocalisés entre
parenthèses
quand il est question de relocalisation
regardons aussi par rapport à ça mais
qui devait faire je sais honnêtement je
me rappelle pas si c'était l'autoroute
ou si c'était pour le ferroviaire pour
autour de autour de la neuve ou de la
ligne de la ligne nouvelle
mais
le matériau qui correspondait le mieux
c'était une carrière qui avait en Lozère
là où j'ai beaucoup
œuvré quand j'étais cheminot cette
carrière elle pouvait
grâce au wagons isolés et je vous dis la
vie le village Le Monastier près de
Marvejols et au-dessus de la Canourgue
et bien elle pouvait charger des wagons
pour aller alimenter
le
[Musique]
disons les matériaux les matériaux et
bien
Bouygues
là
et nous
on était pour elle a SNCF la pas pu
parce qu'il fallait
deux locomotives
étant donné que à certaines endroits il
y a une pente et que deux locomotives
c'est trop cher et donc qu'est-ce que si
c'est trop cher on met pas les
locomotive et on met des centaines de
camions sur la route pour
donc on a là je veux dire
voyez et c'est pour illustrer ce que
disait Francis sur la question des
wagons isolés il s'agit pas d'opposer
les traits
et Dieu sait si j'en sais quelque chose
aussi puisque
dans les Pyrénées nous avons nous cette
plateforme qui nous permet de faire mais
compris nous l'avons fait compris dans
les Pyrénées quand on l'a fait la grande
vitesse entre Nîmes et Montpellier on a
fait en sorte et ça c'est une décision
du gouvernement
où j'avais la responsabilité
que les trains de marchandises puissent
circuler qu'elle soit mixte que la
grande vitesse soit mixte
c'est-à-dire que c'est pas
360 km à l'heure c'est à 320
c'est à 220 pardon c'est pas 300 km/h
c'est à 220 on peut faire voyager des
trains de marchandises et des trains de
voyageurs entre Nîmes et Montpellier
donc
il s'agit pas de poser la grande les
trains très longue comme on dit avec les
cet avantage que nous avions la France
comparé à tous les autres pays européens
et bien c'est ce que proposait ce que
nous proposions que proposer Francis et
bien cet avantage il a pas été utilisé
et par contre l'avantage de la
libéralisation a été mieux utilisé par
d'autres pays
que par l'autre
merci merci monsieur le ministre en
accord avec le rapporteur on va faire
circuler la parole sur les colonnes et
parmi les six députés présents je crois
que Monsieur sangsue député du Cher
avait une question à poser vous avez la
parole de chers collègues
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Ministre merci Monsieur le
Préfet juste un petit mot pour Monsieur
roll Tanguy vous avez souligné que
depuis 2003 le fraté SNCF perdait de
l'argent et qu'en fait c'est au moment
où il y a un redressement qui mène s'il
n'est pas florissant de cette branche
que la Commission attaque et qu'on
arrive à cet accord qui vient démembrer
quand même une grande partie du service
public du fret porté par la SNCF est-ce
que vous pouvez à votre avis puisque on
est dans une commission d'enquête et
vous avez le droit de donner votre avis
pourquoi c'est maintenant que cette
que la Commission européenne attaque
la France et dans ce cadre et diriez
vous que le frais de ferroviaire comme
les petites lignes ont été quand même
sacrifié sur l'excellence du tout TGV
alors
c'est plus facile de répondre à la
dernière question celle d'avant oui
c'est sûr que je veux dire il y a eu
cette
un cette focalisation il faut bien dire
que enfin pour défendre la SNCF à la
SNCF c'est
vue depuis le ministère des Finances ça
n'est qu'un gouffre financier voilà donc
voilà c'est à partir du moment où il y a
cette vision et cette discussion
s'engage toujours sur ses bases là
naturellement que du côté de la SNCF on
cherche ce qui peut marcher et de ce
point de vue moi je le redis je veux
dire je pourrais peut-être faire
d'autres critiques sur Guillaume Pepy
mais la stratégie qu'il a mise en place
rappelle que même enfin bon pour refaire
de l'histoire il a avant le grand
conflit de 95 qui était quand même lié
aussi au contrat de plan Guillaume Pépi
était directeur de la stratégie il a
quitté la SNCF parce qu'il voulait
imposer cette stratégie de volume sur le
TGV et on a dit non on va faire comme on
va faire comme l'aérien c'est là que ça
a donné des mouvements d'usagés sur le
Paris Lille d'inauguration de paradis et
de la mise en oeuvre de cette stratégie
avec des tarifs absolument incroyables
voilà puis derrière il y a le conflit de
95 c'était permis de terminer sur le
chantier et en 97 bah je veux dire Louis
Gallois propose à Guillaume Pépi de
revenir juste après l'arrivée de la
gauche au pouvoir et naturellement le
fait venir sur sa stratégie de volume et
elle a marché je veux dire faut pas faut
pas non plus dire le contraire mais il
faut bien voir que la SNCF vise ou cette
pression permanente de la dépense
publique vous coûter trop cher
moi j'aurais juste te dire un mot sur
rajouter par rapport à Jean-Claude sur
RF c'est sûr que la question était posée
à l'arrivée en juin 97 de remettre en
cause la réforme de février 97 c'est un
contestable bon je veux dire c'est
peut-être pas bien mais je vais le dire
comme ça maintenant nous on l'a échangé
contre un désendettement supplémentaire
de la SNCF
parce que c'est toujours le problème
permanent on laisse la SNCF s'endetter
et puis il y a un moment bah c'est plus
soutenable je veux dire donc voilà mais
c'est comme ça qu'on maintient la
pression sur la SNCF c'est avec cette
problématique de l'endettement donc
voilà donc je sais pas si c'est le
passage d'ingénieur économiste mais
c'est comme ça que c'est quand même ça
la question importante après pourquoi la
Commission vient aujourd'hui
je dirais d'autant plus que la plainte
des opérateurs concurrents de la SNCF
qu'ils avaient déposé il y a quelques
années il venait de la retirer voilà je
m'excuse je veux dire il y a une vraie
question sur ce sujet et c'est pour ça
alors pour le coup je vais sortir de mon
rôle que je ne comprends pas qui est pas
une réponse politique pour dire non et
moi je vais vous dire moi mon sentiment
je sais pas si j'ai raison et encore une
fois là je dis comme opinion personnelle
c'est comme on est en train de négocier
d'autres choses difficiles avec la
Commission
et je vais le dire comme je le pense sur
le nucléaire
naturellement sur d'autres choses on
peut pas dire là aussi circuler il y a
rien à voir je ferai différemment
[Musique]
je sais pas comment on remonte quand on
perd des marchés qui repasse sur
d'autres logiques de logistique bah
c'est pas du jour au lendemain que les
chargeurs changent leur logistique je
veux dire c'est normal c'est compliqué
pour donc oui voilà moi c'est comme ça
que je vois les choses je suis pas sûr
du tout que j'ai raison mais
ta vérité c'est sa vérité à lui et c'est
bien ça c'est bon mais alors mais alors
cette idée quand même cette idée quand
même de vous savez on parle de la
sidérurgie en tout cas parler c'est toi
qui a parlé d'harcelor non quelqu'un il
se trouve que Arcelor
alimente saint-chélier d'Apcher
une usine sidérurgique en Lozère
il y avait mille salariés quand j'étais
il y a la 300 et quelques cela fait
l'entreprise industrielle en Lozère
qui fait quoi elle fait des pièces
métalliques à l'acier
importer depuis Marseille
qui passe par le sevenol
qui monte
jusqu'à clairement qui redescend sur le
viaduc de Garabit construit par Eiffel
donc nous allons fêter le centenaire
et qui alimente l'entreprise de
Saint-Chély-d'Apcher je vous raconte ça
parce que c'est assez intéressant sur le
plan de
ce de cette ces enjeux majeurs dont je
parlais au début si le travail et le
père de toutes les richesses c'est la
planète qui en est la mer et bien
à cette usine là avec la direction
d'Arcelor
et organisé non seulement la défense de
la ligne
SNCF toujours menacé
parce que si elle peut pas charger
ça fera il y a qu'elle importe
d'ailleurs
et bien elle ferme l'entreprise de
Saint-Chély café et à
saint-chélier-d'apcher grâce
et disons
à une chaufferie qui a été installée
tous c'est l'économie je dirais
circulaire les pièces métalliques c'est
uniquement pour les voitures électriques
les pièces métalliques spéciales c'est
que pour les voitures électriques
fabriquées entre parenthèses dans le
Nord et en France
les avec l'eau chaude qui est créé ils
alimentent la
ville de Saint-Chély-d'Apcher
et tous les déchets sans exception sont
retraités c'est-à-dire que tu as
l'économie circulaire on en parle pas de
l'économie circulaire mais vous voyez
cette dimension là c'est c'est tout à
fait vous savez
personnellement et je suis pas le seul
bon quand on l'a développé le TGV y
compris qui en tige on a réussi à faire
tout ce qu'on a fait avec le TGV compris
j'étais de ceux pour le vendre ailleurs
à l'étranger et et on a fait des choses
mais je suis contre le tout TGV
parce que si c'est au détriment
des lignes se dites secondaires c'est au
détriment du chemin de fer c'est
pareil pour le taux nucléaire je suis
contre le tout nucléaire je suis pour le
nucléaire
mais contre voilà je crois que cette
logique
il s'en fout la réponse
je crois que vraiment cette logique tout
ce que vous pourrez aider à faire bouger
contre la
l'ultra libéralisme
ce sera une bonne chose
je vais passer la parole aux collègues
des petites Seine-Saint-Denis Thomas
porte juste une pour rebondir sur ce que
vous disiez sur le Tanguy ce moment
c'est aussi celui où dB cargo elle-même
est en ce moment dans des échanges avec
la Commission européenne qui ne sont pas
simples non plus c'est pas un moment qui
n'est que français le moment un peu
particulier qu'on vit en ce moment
monsieur le député vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Préfet vous n'êtes
pas le seul cheminot parce que je suis
aussi cheminot en disponibilité donc je
suis ravi de vous auditionner sur cette
question du frais de ferroviaire qui
nous préoccupe moi j'ai trois questions
la première vous avez beaucoup insisté
sur la question du wagon isolé sur le
sur laquelle on se bat depuis des années
pour dire que c'est une des priorités
pour vous pourquoi ce wagon isolé il a
été abandonné qu'est-ce que c'est la
quelle décision à conduire à son abandon
alors que tout le monde disait que
c'était une des solutions et aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'une relance du fret
ferroviaire publique en France ça passe
d'abord et par la relance du wagon isolé
et comment on fait pour relancer le
wagon isolé la deuxième question vous
avez parlé des de l'argent et des
ressources financières pour avoir une
grande politique publique de transport
ferroviaire marchandise et voyageurs on
parle souvent de rentabilité nous on
défend l'idée qu'il y a aussi une
rentabilité écologique et sociale au
train qui qui est très utile vous avez
parlé de la question des autoroutes
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est pour vous
un des piliers qui permettrait aussi de
relancer le frais de ferroviaire d'avoir
une politique iron nationalise les
autoroutes pour dégager de l'argent et
remettre dans le train est-ce que vous
pouvez vous nous confirmer que vous êtes
favorable à cette idée là et la
troisième c'est sur la question des
sciences moi je l'ai vécu en tant que
chef circulation à la SNCF c'est à dire
qu'on avait des trains qui étaient en
retard on nous a appelé pour dire le
train de fret on le met sur le côté on
le on le libère que trois quatre cinq
heures après et on laisse passer tous
les trains de voyageurs et évidemment
quand vous êtes une entreprise que vous
mettez des wagons sur un train que votre
train il est prévu d'arriver le lundi à
18h et qu'il arrive que le lundi dans la
nuit ou le mardi matin ça vous pose
souci est-ce qu'il faudrait pas avoir
une politique à revoir sur les siens
aujourd'hui pour ne plus forcément
prioriser le transport de voyageurs et
péjoré autant le transport de
marchandises et les garer pour être
utilisés en termes cheminots sur les
côtés dès qu'il y a un peu de retard
parce que derrière on a des entreprises
qui nous solliciter en disant bah
écoutez nous on avait fait le choix de
prendre le train et puis finalement au
bout de six mois on s'est aperçu que la
régularité de notre train elle était
plus efficiente donc on est passé par la
route voilà les trois questions sur
lesquelles je voulais vous vous
interroger encore merci d'avoir répondu
à cette commission d'enquête
voilà d'abord sur les wagons isolés je
vais pas répéter ce que Francis a dit ce
que je dis mais par contre
ma réaction à la question est-ce que ça
passe par les wagons et isolées la
solution au problème
si ça passait que par ça donc je dis que
c'est un des aspect oui mais qu'il faut
aller d'ailleurs la deuxième question
elle prouve que ça passe ça peut pas
passer que par le wagon isolé donc
surtout ne pas opposer et
relancer de wagons isolés partout c'est
possible et puis j'ai dit un mot que
vous avez sûrement entendu
les plateformes multimodale
les plateformes multimodal il en existe
en France et là aussi il y a des
problèmes de financement il y a des
problèmes d'élargissement il y a des
problèmes pour passer
de la route orale du canal aura de la
mer aura
c'est
les enjeux la multimodalité et
l'intermodalité mais en priorisant
tous ceux qui vont dans le sens et bien
oui du coup de réduire le coût
environnemental ce que tu as dit je
partage 1000% mais tu parlais des
comment l’appeler ça prendre en compte
le coup
ça porte un
les cours externes mais bien sûr
c'est une dimension essentielle ou alors
il faut pas parler de lutter contre les
gaz à effet de serre de lutter contre le
bien sûr et nationaliser
oui
je dis pas étatisé
parce que on a souvent un problème avec
cette question il s'agit pas de penser
qu'on va
régler les problèmes en l'administrant
il faut pas faire du Soviet suprême
moi je suis contre toutes les dictatures
sans exception
je dis bien toutes les dictatures mais
l'idée est donc
penser que y compris du moment qu'on est
dans cette dimension là que toutes les
lignes sans exception
que ce soit les petites les secondaires
les lignes du territoire et les lignes
grande vitesse
non seulement doivent être
maintenu et que s'il faut en ouvrir
d'autres
regardons mais il y a le problème des
sillons qui se posent quand je dis tout
à l'heure
faire
du transport fret ferroviaire un
véritable service public comme nous le
concevons pour le voyageur c'est ma
philosophie je l'ai écrite cette
philosophie et je non seulement je suis
à 100% d'accord avec cette idée là et
donc regardons pour les sillons
y compris pour bien articuler
parce que sinon comme le comme c'est pas
considéré comme un service public ça
passe après et après on le dit ben oui
mais qu'est-ce que tu veux non
il faut travailler sur ces questions et
travailler pour que le service public de
fret ferroviaire ne sont pas considérés
comme secondaire
voilà est-ce que ça te sied
dans les 5 minutes qui restent et sur le
Tanguy en réaction aux collègues de
Thomas porte on pourra peut-être pas
prendre de questions je pense parce que
on a Patrick Gentet qui qui vient après
alors Monsieur Marchaux et Madame ténia
mais très très rapidement peut-être et
peut-être vous répondrez en bloc sur le
Tanguy monsieur Marchaux et madame tigna
monsieur le député madame la députée
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre devant le Sénat le 29 mars 2001
vous êtes félicité de l'adoption donc le
22 novembre 2000 du projet de trois
directives européennes que vous avez
négocier au Conseil des ministres
européens des transports notamment qui
ouvrait à la concurrence internationale
le fret je vous cite au Sénat l'adoption
le 22 novembre dernier des trois projets
de directives constituant le paquet
ferroviaire à concrétiser l'accord
politique réalisé en conseil des
ministres de transport de décembre 1999
sous présidente accord qui doit beaucoup
à la France je vous je puis vous
l'assurer est-ce que vous considérez que
c'est aujourd'hui une erreur puisque ça
a été un acte dans la libéralisation à
l'ouverture à la concurrence parce que
il y a eu éventuellement des pressions
de la Commission européenne ou une
dépression également des entreprises
utilisant le fret à l'époque
on va prendre la question de notre
collègue député du Lot hugattignia vous
écoute
vous avez évoqué dans votre présentation
l'argument financier qui a conduit
justement à
dire la 18 études du fait ferroviaire
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
moi ce qui m'étonne c'est que le frère
ferroviaire on sait qu'elle a beaucoup
d'avantages par rapport au fait routier
et je me posais la question si à
l'époque il n'y avait pas du tout un
argument écologique qui aurait pu aussi
peser dans la balance avec l'argument
financier pour essayer de maintenir le
fret ou en tout cas faire en sorte que
on ne soit pas dans la situation
actuelle du fret merci peut-être du coup
sur sur en réaction tout à l'heure et
puis monsieur le ministre pour terminer
Monsieur le Préfet donc retombe vous
avez la parole
répondre rapidement sur le wagon isolé
puisque c'est sûrement un peu au cœur du
système moi je dirais il y a une chose
qui est certaine et vous le savez tous
on vous en livrez peut-être vous y
refuser mais en tous les cas on
constatant qu'on livre tous les jours
des petits paquets voilà c'est que le
marché n'est plus à faire des terrains
de 1000 de 1000 3000 tonnes par un seul
chargeur donc soit on dit on veut du
frais de ferroviaire et on se met à la
taille de ce que sont les emplois des
envois des chargeurs soit on fait pas de
frais de ferroviaire il faut quand même
il faut quand même lui dire donc c'est
pas une question de wagon isolé pour le
mythe du wagon isolé mais si il y a pas
de capacité avant d'un produit de
l'ordre du 38 tonnes ou de 2 38 tonnes
je veux dire il y a aucune solution et
regardez dans le transport routier qui
gagne de l'argent aujourd'hui c'est les
entreprises de messagerie c'est pas
celle qui font du camion
de la charge complète comme c'est ceux
qui remplissent avec des petits colis
qui vont de rien du tout à 50 ou 100 kg
et à une palette c'est ça je dirais
c'est ça que j'ai au 10 c'est là où j'ai
E10 gagne je veux dire et donc c'est
bien que c'est possible je veux dire
c'est vrai que dans le frais de
ferroviaire aujourd'hui on n'est pas
toujours sûr d'où sont les wagons alors
que il y a pas un conteneur qui se
balade sur la planète qu'on ne sait pas
repéré par l'informatique c'est bien des
problèmes de sous-investissement de cet
ordre qui fait qu'on s'en sort pas donc
je veux dire il y a pas photo si on veut
que le frais de faire revenir existe il
faut repasser à des tailles à vendre une
charge qui soit à la taille des envois
des chargeurs sinon il y en aura pas
donc moi je veux dire c'est la seule
chose juste dire un mot après sur on a
dit il y a eu des pertes sur le
transport combiné moi quand je te
directeur du fret on perdait de l'argent
sur le transport combiné oui mais un
qu'est-ce que ça voulait dire ça voulait
dire qu'il fallait que on se réorganise
et je vous parle enfin je vais pas
rentrer là sur les idées qu'on avait sur
le sujet et sur les choses qu'on a
commencé à mettre en oeuvre mais quand
vous avez un marché je veux dire on a
dit le doublement du frais de
ferroviaire c'était un leurre bah ouais
mais le trafic conteneur du port de
Rotterdam entre 2000 et 2010 il a bien
doublé lui et ça c'est pas un leurre
donc je veux dire donc si vous voulez je
veux dire c'était le marché d'avenir sur
lequel il fallait travailler pour être
effectivement dans le dans la cible je
veux dire c'est tout c'est dire je
l'abandonne bah je veux dire c'était si
j'abandonne ce marché là bah je veux
dire on n'existe plus et c'est quand
même c'est ça qui fait qu'on en est là
et on termine par vous monsieur le
ministre sur les deux questions des
collègues donc si je résume celle de du
député Marcio cette impression que vous
avez retardé cette libéralisation mais
que finalement le premier paquet
ferroviaire c'est aussi vous donc que
vous l'avez avalisé je résume et la
remarque de notre collègue député Tignac
qui fait écho à ce qu'on peut observer
dans les débats publics de la fin des
années 90 début des années 2000 à savoir
que la préoccupation écologique était
finalement assez peu présente dans le
débat public à ce moment là quand on
défendait le Fred ferroviaire
c'est vrai que
j'apprécie la question
ça me permet d'être tranquille pour la
réponse
monsieur le président
alors
Voilà il se trouve que on parle du
premier paquet
et
vous avez entendu la 91 à 440
c'était bien avant
premier paquet ferroviaire
et là il est question de réseau
européen
du fret ferroviaire c'est ça
réseau
rtf
et je suis nous sommes dans cette
situation
où justement
parce que
le
la
801440 et le premier paquet ferroviaire
et décider par l'Europe au nom
de lutter contre le déclin du transport
ferroviaire
en Europe c'est ça l'argument
et pour constituer l'Europe des
transports et c'est le 4e paquet qui
achèvera cette
cette logique là
le deuxième paquet ferroviaire
c'est en 2004
et je me suis battu
contre le premier paquet ferroviaire
nous sommes confrontés à cette situation
de permettre
que pour les transports européens pour
le réseau européen du transport
marchandise de permettre à une
entreprise qu'elle s'appelle dB ou
qu'elle s'appelle à la rentrée ou
qu'elle s'appelle
la SNCF
de pouvoir
traverser l'Europe
et j'accepte et j'accepte en mettant une
condition
que les règles
et la législation
concernant
chaque pays
soit sauvegardé
vous entendez ce que je dis je sais pas
si vous avez site on a toujours dit ça
parce que comme
effectivement
faire passer un train de la DB qui
traverse la France
et qui va qui va en Espagne et
bien oui si ça permet et c'est
uniquement là-dessus ce n'est qu'ensuite
au deuxième et au troisième paquet que
il y a eu la possibilité du cabotage
et avec
la décision qu'on a prise justement on
en était
je vous ai dit à 0,1% et d'ailleurs le
premier train qui a été si ma mémoire
est bonne Francis tu me diras
si je crois en 2005 qui a eu un premier
train qui est passé
mais qui a été bloqué par mes camarades
de la CGT pendant quelques jours pour
justement contre l'idée ce café dire à
certains webguesso pourquoi tu as ouvert
je vous explique le pourquoi je vous
explique la raison et je vous assure
c'est
peut-être je sais pas peut-être il
aurait fallu que
qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire aussi
moi je n'étais pas
que ce soit à l'Europe
que ce soit en France
quand tu es ministre
tu es tu es c'est pas c'est pas ton
parti c'est pas le programme de ton
parti que tu imposes mais c'est ce qui a
été décidé
en commun par la gauche pluriel voilà
donc
juste pour répondre aussi il faut
conclure sur l'écologie peut-être parce
qu'on a on doit enchaîner avec d'autres
d'autres auditions et je voudrais pas
faire trop attendre
toutes les personnes qui vont succéder
cet après-midi alors sur les sur
l'écologie à l'environnement
franchement
enfin vous m'avez entendu
et je vous encourage d'ailleurs
parmi parmi les documents que vous
pouvez monsieur le Président et monsieur
le rapporteur
parmi les documents que vous pourriez
retrouver
il se trouve que
j'ai
fait faire un livre sur les 5 années
passées au ministère oh
tout sera fait de bien ou pas bien
et sur la partie
environnement
écologique je vous ai dit mon ADN
mon ADN je vous ai cité même mars
de toutes les richesses c'est la planète
qui en est la mer et Georges et j'ajoute
soit dans les comme la prunelle de nos
yeux
le travail ça veut dire les travailleurs
et les travailleurs
et la planète c'est à dire la terre la
mer
et l'espace
et
j'en suis là et mes responsabilités
aujourd'hui
y compris
concernant l'espace
pour la Méditerranée
pour nos relations avec l'Afrique
compris avec le Maroc
et bien vise à ce que cette dimension
dans toutes les décisions que nous avons
à prendre intègre
ces cours externes dont on parlait que
ce soit pour la biodiversité que ce soit
pour
mettre tout ça je suis
j'ai quelques semaines ou quelques mois
à vivre étant donné mon âge mais
jusqu'au bout je me battrai pour ça et
pour moi
l'écologie c'est pas un supplément d'âme
c'est un élément essentiel dans le cadre
du développement durable c'est-à-dire je
suis pas pour le sous-développement
durable parce que je suis aussi pour la
lutte contre les injustices et les
inégalités de Parlement
merci merci beaucoup Michel le ministre
merci Monsieur le Tanguy de cette
audition et donc et du témoignage que
vous nous avez apporté sur les
différents points sur lesquels les
collègues députés ont pu vous interroger
merci beaucoup merci à vous et bravo